YouTube has become a paid to win gone
are the days that random Joe's could
pick up cameras and record themselves
playing games or discussing a topic
nowadays everyone from MKBHD and Mr
who's the boss to Iraq and Mr Beast to
spend it tens of thousands if not
hundreds of thousands on each and every
video they also all have a millions of
dollars worth of equipment dedicated
Studios and dozens of employees at this
point they're pretty much just full-on
Production Studios and that's on the
personality side of YouTube itself
then you have the whole company side as
well with the channels like Brightside
the infographic show T-Series and the
cocomelon nursery rhymes there are a few
outliers who have stuck to a reasonable
level of production like Sniper Wolf and
penguin but these are very much the
exception not the rule
also most of these guys were ogs to
YouTube trying to replicate their
formula today from scratch probably
wouldn't work all that well this is
quite a shame as raw authenticity is
what made YouTube different from
traditional media Platforms in the first
place people liked that they could see
their favorite creators without
censorship without filters and without
Advertiser influence people like the
genuine and the vulnerable nature of
YouTube but modern creators shy away
from these characteristics as much as
possible
these attributes simply lead to drama
controversy and potentially getting
canceled so the best solution is to just
stay as vanilla as possible
never have an opinion never push the
boundaries and never ever piss off the
people on Twitter larger creators are
simply leaning into these attributes as
it allows them to Outsource more work
create a better distinction between
their personal lives and their online
personas and it gives them a larger mode
against aspiring up and coming creators
so a pretty smart strategy from their
end but this is arguably destroying the
essence of YouTube so here's how YouTube
became paid to win it and the upsetting
future of the platform
taking a look back the roots of this
Evolution can be traced back to the
mid-2010s to creators by this point most
niches had already become saturated with
the tons of craters people were starting
to understand that YouTube couldn't not
only be a viable career but a lucrative
one that came with popularity Fame and
influence so it's no wonder why people
were jumping at every opportunity they
saw but this brought along with it to
quite a few challenges larger creators
often struggled to keep up with the
quantity of content from smaller
creators it was also super difficult to
think of original ideas as every topic
you can think of had already been
covered from every aspect you can think
of the saying it there are no original
ideas was truer than ever but despite
this creators attempted to keep up with
the YouTube machine leading to burnout
and the high levels of stress and
depression a few notable creators
however were able to find an escape from
this vicious hamster wheel these guys
accepted that they would never be able
to keep up with the fire hose of content
that was being put up on YouTube if they
were a tech YouTuber there were simply
too many smartphones laptops and gadgets
coming out to cover them all
if they were a vlogger it was simply
impossible to make their lives
interesting every single day of the year
this was simply not sustainable so these
creators decided to take another path
instead of trying to cover every single
topic they decided to Simply cover one
topic better than anyone the idea is
that people would tune in not because
the ideas or concepts were unique but
because the delivery was exceptional a
perfect example of this is Marcus
Brownlee somewhere along the line Marcus
decided to drop a quarter million
dollars on a robotic camera let me just
say there is no way to quantifiably
justify this investment you can't be
like oh this camera is going to increase
my viewership by 6.2 percent so in 42
months the ROI will be net positive it
simply does not work because it's
unlikely that this camera led to any
sort of noticeable increase in
viewership at least not in the short
term but that's okay this camera was not
purchased to boost viewership this
camera was purchased to build a brand
perception whenever you see a crazy
camera shot on Tech YouTube you know
it's Marcus and this Association gets
him one step closer to being the
Undisputed king of tech YouTubers so the
next time an iPhone drops it doesn't
matter if a hundred people post reviews
about it before Marcus you can bet that
millions of people are waiting to see
Marcus's take specifically because he
provides an experience that they can't
get anywhere else on YouTube Marcus is
by no means the only one at leveraging
the strategy either this strategy has
become very prevalent with Mr Beast
Channel as well take a few of his recent
videos for example one dollar versus 500
000 plane ticket and a one dollar versus
one million dollar hotel room these are
by no means a groundbreaking video ideas
BuzzFeed made identical videos six years
ago in fact they had a full-on series
called worth it to comparing cheap
options to expensive options yet Mr
BEAST's plane video got 150 million
views and his hotel video got 217
million views why simple his skill and
the production those are just two
examples but I could name dozens
Mr who's the boss airrod magnates media
good mythical morning Mark Rober stuff
made here film Theory gen how tan and
Wong Fu Productions and basically every
other large Channel you can think of
while their initial success may have
been fueled by down-to-earth mortal
videos it's their production quality
that's kept them at the top
[Music]
it's not just the creators who have
evolved either audiences have also very
much evolved back in 2007 and 2008 let
me just be real here the people who
watched YouTube were a bunch of
anti-social nerds and The Gamers but
nowadays everyone watches YouTube and
with that it comes along a vastly
different set of expectations most
people are used to TV Netflix and movies
and to them that level of production is
normal so naturally these people flock
the channels that are able to live up to
these standards
also let me say this is not a trend
that's unique to YouTube in general
people flock to high production value
content take Avatar 2 for example the
storyline was at best mundane but this
has proved to be completely irrelevant
as Avatar 2 ended up as the third
highest grossing film of all time the
same thing could be said about the
original Avatar as well while the
storyline was more substantial than
Avatar 2 critics argued that it was just
a ripoff of Dances with Wolves
this is very much true and even James
Cameron himself has admitted this but
that didn't stop Avatar 2 from becoming
the highest grossing film of all time
why you ask well the visuals are
stunning The World building is
unbelievable and you forget that it's
even CGI
now this isn't to say that Cameron or
creators should come up with the crappy
storylines and buff it up with the
visuals not a good strategy ideally the
story is good and the production is good
that would obviously lead to the best
results but the thing to note is that a
good production can make up for a bad
story a good story however doesn't
always make up for a bad production at
least with the general audience
another great example of this is the
Grand Theft Auto series the GTA Series
has been around for 25 years at this
point and while there are some
differences between the games like the
city that it's based in it all boils
down to the same thing you're a bad guy
doing bad things to make money and earn
respect simple as that but despite
milking the same plot for so long GTA 5
ended up becoming the highest grossing
piece of media of all time pulling in
7.7 billion dollars and we can only
imagine how well GTA 6 will perform the
reasoning is simple Rockstar Games is
constantly creating an unmatchable
experience with each and every iteration
so when audiences are constantly being
fed this level of content by movies TV
shows and games it's only natural that
they come to expect the same from
YouTube the creators that are able to
keep up do exceptionally well the others
well the others are left behind
[Music]
creators often like to blame the
algorithm when it comes to a video and
not performing well or the channel being
killed off audiences also like to
complain that platforms are recommending
thirst traps and a low productivity
content but the truth is that both of
these parties are just shifting the
blame the algorithms of social media
platforms are nothing but audience
psychology so if a video isn't
performing well or a channel is
receiving less views it's not because
the algorithm doesn't like the content
it's because the audience doesn't like
the content at least not a broad
audience the opposite is true as well if
a channel is performing really well it's
not because YouTube is biased or
something it's because that's what the
audience wants to see and based on who
the biggest creators are today it's
cleared out what the audience wants is a
fast-paced high production value content
which brings us to our main question
where does that leave small creators
well not in a good place also when I say
small creators I don't mean people with
hundreds of thousands of subscribers or
even tens of thousands I'm talking about
people who are trying to get their first
thousand or their first 5 000
subscribers as Casey neistat once said
ten thousand Subs
is the hardest thing to do on YouTube
Because at zero nobody's tuning in
nobody cares and that this is harder
than ever today because top creators
have simply set the bar for entry so
high now there's no point in blaming
these craters not only do they produce
awesome content that's enjoyed by
hundreds of millions of people but
they're just doing what's best for their
brands and their businesses that's only
reasonable but with that being said it
this trend has largely shifted the tide
against new creators in fact 97 of
YouTubers don't make it which isn't not
that different from Hollywood where only
two percent of actors make it most small
creators today are hoping for that one
viral video that will explode their
Channel but this is not that different
from actors and musicians hoping for
that one lucky break
the reality is that this break will
never come for most people
now a lot of creators will have you
believe that it's not a lock and that it
comes down to one's understanding of
YouTube and the audience
Mr Beast has even claimed that he could
get to 1 million subscribers from zero
within three to four months how long
would it take you to get to 1 million
subscribers probably three months maybe
four from zero easily three or four
months like if that's all that guy was
doing and they're right succeeding on
YouTube is not necessarily Vlog but the
thing to note is that creators that are
starting off also don't have the same
skills or mindset it's like those shows
where millionaires try to start from
zero and become millionaires again
admittedly these are super interesting
to watch but to think that a homeless
guy could do it just because a
millionaire could it is absurd similarly
thinking that an average Joe could get
to a million subscribers in three months
or even a year just because Mr Beast
could is also absurd of course there
will be exceptions but that's what they
are exceptions
the harsh reality is that making it on
YouTube is becoming harder and harder
every day because the bar of Entry is
also becoming higher and higher
[Music]
in the end the state of YouTube today is
not out of the ordinary by any means
that's how every other artistic industry
has always been at whether that be Games
movies TVs writing or art itself the
reason that this is upsetting with
YouTube though is because YouTube used
to be the exception they started off
like be real but expecting them to stay
this way is simply unrealistic be real
is already dying and if YouTube chose
this path they too would probably be
dead the reason that YouTube is so
successful today is because they evolved
they became more like traditional media
and the creators followed suit with all
that being said though if you are able
to make it to the other side the
opportunity on YouTube is insane
but getting to the other side is harder
than ever because YouTube has become pay
to win do you prefer the old YouTube or
the new YouTube comment that down below
also drop a like if you've been
appreciating the high production quality
on this channel and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community
suggest for the video ideas and consider
subscribing to more questions and
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one